WIM MEEUSSEN: Welcome,
and thank you for coming.
I know it's been a long day.
I think this is probably
the last talk for today.
So I appreciate your being here.
I'll try to keep
it very exciting.
I have a lot of
live demos lined up.
So hopefully this will be fun.
So my name is Wim Meeussen.
And I lead the developer
engineering team
for the Asia-Pacific region.
And today I want to
talk a little bit
about why we are
investing in Tango
and why we care so much
about this technology.
I want to go into
what exactly Tango is
and what kind of experiences
you can enable on top of Tango.
And then, of course, this
is a developer conference.
I want to talk about
how you, as a developer,
can use Tango to
build new experiences.
So first, I guess,
before I start,
I always like to get an
idea of your backgrounds.
So by raise of hands, who
has heard about Project Tango
before today?
That's about, let's say,
a third of the room.
Great.
And then maybe the
harder question.
Has anyone developed
on Tango before?
No developers?
OK, this is awesome.
So today I will show you how
you can get started on Tango.
I'll show you the experiences
that you can build.
So let's first do a little
introduction in Tango.
So fundamentally Tango is
about using computer vision
to allow your mobile device to
understand the world around it.
And as people, we have
this really amazing skill.
We can just look at the
world and really understand
the geometry, and we
understand how we move.
That's kind of amazing.
It's just light
coming into our eye.
And then our brain is
processing those signals.
And based on that, we know
how to operate in the world.
As a person, if you
look at this scene,
you immediately understand that
this wide blob is a place where
you can go sit down.
And you know the brown area
is a place where you can walk.
Or as a person, just
by looking at a scene,
you would know where you could
put down a glass of water.
Or you can recognize
a dangerous situation,
like somewhere where
you have to watch out,
just by looking at the scene.
And we want to give
your mobile device some
of those same capabilities.
So with Tango, instead
of seeing this scene
as just millions and
millions of pixels,
we want your phone
to really understand
the geometry of that room.
And we want your
phone to understand
how it moves through the space.
So with Tango, we're
using computer vision
to really give your mobile
device an understanding
of space and motion.
So maybe that sounds
all a little hand-wavy.
So let me just show you a demo.
I'll show you the app that
you get to see when you first
buy a Tango phone.
This is the welcome
experience that you get.
And I have this Go Pro rig.
It's not perfect, but
it really shows you
what the experience would be.
Could we switch to the demo?
So this is a welcome
experience for Tango.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
There you go.
[APPLAUSE]
So this really gives
you an idea of all
the different
capabilities of Tango.
And we'll go into
a lot more detail
during the rest of this talk.
So to look a little bit
at what's coming up.
So first I'll talk about
exactly what is Tango.
What is the hardware?
What are the software
building blocks?
And how did we construct it?
Then I'll give an overview
of all the different types
of experiences that you
can build with Tango,
like going from AR to VR
to video stabilization
to-- even to navigation.
So we'll cover the
entire spectrum.
Then I'll go into
much more depth
and explain step by step how you
can build an augmented reality
experience.
And of course, we're in China.
So I want to talk about
how can you use Tango
as a developer in China.
What are all the tools
and building blocks
that we have available for you?
So let's get started.
What is Tango?
What exactly is it?
So first we'll go
into the hardware,
because Tango runs on
custom hardware that
enables these kind of
computer vision capabilities.
So I want to give you a little
bit of an overview of where
we've come in the
last four years
as we've been building Tango.
So back in 2012, we started
out with just an idea.
We had this sketch.
We had this idea for what would
be possible on a mobile device.
A little later, we built
our first prototype.
So I found this really
old picture of one
of our very first prototypes
built into plexiglass.
After that, we
started looking at can
we reduce the form
factor for Tango?
Can we make all the
components smaller?
Can we deal with
all the thermals?
And can we create it
into a phone form factor?
And then about two years ago--
this was one too fast--
about two years ago, we released
our first Tango developer kit.
So this was still a
platform at small scale
to give our developers a
preview of what Tango could do,
so they could experience
Tango even before we publicly
released a real device.
And I'm really exciting,
just last month, Lenovo
announced their first
consumer Tango device.
And this device will
be launched worldwide.
It'll also be available
here in China.
So let's break down
the phone a little
and think about all these
different prototypes.
They have three
things in common.
Those are the three
specific things
that every Tango
enabled phone has.
So first, every Tango
device has the ability
to sense 3D in the world.
So every Tango device
has a depth sensor.
Second, every Tango device
has a wide angle motion
tracking camera.
And this allows
your device to know
how it moves through space.
And then, of course, to
do all the heavy computer
vision processing, we have
a special vision processing
chip in every device.
So the Lenovo device comes with
a Qualcomm Snapdragon chip.
So these are the
three components,
the specific hardware specs
that you need to have a Tango
compliant device.
And if we take a
little bit of a step
back and look at mobile
phones, some time
not too long ago a phone was
meant to make phone calls.
And then slowly over time, more
and more pieces of hardware
got added to it.
At some point, cameras became
standard on every phone.
Accelerometers came, gyros,
GPS is of course in every phone
right now.
And then more recently, you've
seen things like fingerprint
sensors on every phone.
And we believe that the
ability for your phone
to see the world in
the same way we do,
for your phone to
understand motion and space,
it's so fundamental in how
we interact with the world
that we believe that
these Tango specs are
inevitable for mobile
phones to also add
this as a next capability.
So let's take a look at
the different software
components that make Tango.
So there's three
core building blocks
that you find on
every Tango device.
So there is motion
tracking, area learning,
and depth perception.
And I'll go into more detail for
each of the three components.
Let me just grab a
phone real quick.
So motion tracking is
kind of what it says.
It allows your device to know
how it moves through space.
So if I start with
my device here,
and I move forward by a
meter, motion tracking
will tell me you moved
forward by a meter.
If I rotate 180 degrees,
motion tracking will tell me,
you moved forward by a meter,
and I rotated 180 degrees.
If I then go back
to where I started,
again, motion
tracking will tell me
that I'm back approximately
to where I started.
So motion tracking tells you
how you go forward, backwards,
left, right, up, down.
And it knows three
different rotations.
So in full six
degrees of freedom,
it knows how your
device moves in space.
So our second building
blog is area learning.
And I want to try something
new with you guys.
I want to try a
little experiment.
So I want to ask everyone, close
your eyes for just a minute.
Everybody eyes closed?
So now point with your
finger to the door
where you came into this room.
Yeah, awesome, thank you.
Everyone of you, as
you walked into here,
you built up a memory of
what this space looked like.
You can open your
eyes again, sorry.
But think about it.
You built up this memory.
You remembered
where the door was.
You remember where
you're sitting.
You probably remember
where the stage is.
So you build up this
memory of your world.
And this is exactly what
Tango does for area learning.
Area learning gives
Tango a memory
so it can recognize a
space it has seen before.
That's our second
building block.
Our third building block
is depth perception.
So because every Tango
device has a depth sensor,
if I point my
device at something,
the depth sensor will be able to
see the geometry of everything
I point at.
So if I point here,
my depth sensor
will be able to see
the surface here.
If I point it at the back, I'll
see the surface of the back.
So everywhere I point
this, I can see the world
in three dimensions
with the depth sensor.
So those are the three core
building blocks for Tango.
So now, I guess, you
have an understanding
of what makes a Tango
hardware unique.
And you understand the
three basic building
blocks in our software SDK.
So let's look at what
are all the things you
can build with this using
these three building blocks?
So I will show a
number of demos now.
And for each of the
demos, I will show you
which of those three
building blocks
that we use to build that demo.
So I'll tell you if something
used motion tracking, area
learning, depth perception,
or a combination of those.
So first let's look
at a VR experience.
So it's not VR as in Daydream
that you have a headset.
This is handheld VR.
So it means that
everything Tango shows you,
it's all virtual.
So let me switch to a demo here.
And I'll show you a fully
VR application in Tango.
It's called Hot Wheels.
You get to race cars.
I'm already at level three.
I earned some coins.
One second, there we go.
So here you can see, I am
in a complete virtual world.
And with Tango, I can
walk around in that world.
And I can go look
at little details.
But everything my
device shows is virtual.
And then from here, I can start
interacting with the world.
If I go to the start of my
track, I can launch my car.
You'll watch it
drive over the track.
So here my Tango phone is this
six degrees of freedom joystick
almost to guide me
through the world.
And I can interact at different
places with the world.
So to build this kind
of VR applications,
let's see what kind of
building blocks you need.
And that is one of
the simplest things
you can do, because all you
need is motion tracking,
because you only
need to know how
are you moving through space.
Once you know how you're moving,
you know what kind of scene
to render.
So that's VR.
Let's look at the next part.
So if we take it
one step further,
what if you want to build an
augmented reality experience?
So let's jump back
to a few demos here.
And I have a few different
apps I wanted to show you.
So the first app allows me
to put a virtual dinosaur
in the real world.
So I can select what
dinosaur I want,
and then just add
it to the world.
And you can go look at it
from all different angles.
You can make it small.
You can make a big.
So let's see.
Let's add a bigger guy here.
Now he's at 55%.
So let's blow him
up all the way.
You can really get a sense
of the size of this animal.
If I go a little
closer, you really
get a sense of this big
animal being right here.
So let's jump to another demo.
So this was more I was
showing you a static object.
But in AR, you can also start
interacting with the world.
Let's show another game.
It's called Domino World.
So in this game, I can
start building my own domino
track on the real world.
So let me build some here.
And I can just place
blocks by moving around.
And then I have a whole toolbox.
If I want to add,
let's say, a bridge,
I can add a bridge to my game.
I can add different
color blocks.
And I can literally freely
walk around in my space.
And maybe we can hop onto
stage and continue right here.
So you can build this entire
track of domino blocks.
And then we can add
some cool effects.
So let's add some explosions
to some of our blocks.
And then maybe try
one more trick.
I don't even know
what it's going to do.
So now that I've created
this virtual domino,
I can just start
it and let it run.
Let me give you some sound.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Let's see what happened.
I added a difficult block.
I do not know how
I can fix this.
[LAUGHTER]
So even in the virtual
world, this is kind of hard.
OK, let me try one more.
I added a few more blocks.
Last attempt.
They're still going.
There we go.
Dominos.
[APPLAUSE]
I could use some practice here.
So one more app I
wanted to show you.
And this one I'm actually
pretty excited about.
So Jingdong has built an app
on top of Tango that allows
you to do online shopping.
But then you can visualize
items in augmented reality.
That's one of the challenges
you have in virtual shopping,
with online shopping.
You don't get a real idea
of what things look like.
So if the Wi-Fi works out, let
me show you what this could be.
So here I can choose
between AR and VR.
So let's pick AR.
And now we're waiting
for the Wi-Fi.
There we go.
So I could scroll through
different products.
So let's say I wanted
to try out a couch.
So this app is live.
It's running right now,
getting data from the internet.
It's also part of
the Lenovo app store.
And let's see if the
Wi-Fi comes through.
Let me just give this a little
bit of time while it's loading,
and talk already about what
the building blocks are
that we need to build these
augmented reality applications.
So obviously, to build this
you need motion tracking,
because, again, we
want to know how
we are moving through space.
But motion tracking
alone is not enough.
In order to know where we
can place virtual objects--
like you want your dinosaur
to be on the ground--
so in order to know where
we can place things,
we also need depth perception.
So to build AR, you need both
motion tracking and depth
perception.
Let me give this one more
try, because it's super cool.
Not enough Wi-Fi, maybe too
many people in one room.
Let's jump back to
the slides then.
So as I talked about for AR,
we need both motion tracking
and depth perception.
With those two building blocks,
you can build these experiences
that you just saw.
So now let's take
a look at things
we can do if you use a
depth sensor for more
advanced capabilities,
because depth sensor
can see the world in 3D.
So let's see what we can
do with an app to start
measuring the real world.
So let's jump back
to the demo here.
This is an app called Measure.
And again, because it's Tango,
I can freely move in space.
So I can come here to the
front and maybe measure
how wide this row of people is.
And I can place my second point.
There we go, three
and a half meters.
So I can just freely
move through space
and start measuring things.
So let's try
something more in 3D.
So let's start measuring some
of the tiles on the floor here.
So now it allows me to
fully extend it and create
a full volume out of it.
So if I go a little
further away,
you can see I can
start measuring areas.
I can start measuring volumes.
And I can just do it
anywhere in the world.
Anywhere where I
can tap and click,
I can start measuring in 3D.
Let's jump back to the slides.
So to enable this 3D
measuring, we actually
will rely on motion tracking
and area learning and depth
perception.
So you probably understand
why you need motion tracking
and why you need depth.
But why do you need
area learning here?
And area learning
is going to help
you to improve your accuracy,
because when I place points
in the world, I want my Tango
device to remember where
exactly it placed those points.
I don't want those points to
start drifting away over time.
So by using area learning and
giving my device a memory,
it can remember exactly
where it placed those points.
And when I walk around and
start putting dots all around,
Tango remembers
where I placed them
and gets more
accurate measurements
than I would otherwise get.
So area learning can help
you to increase the accuracy
and reduce drift
for your device.
Let's look at what
if we go all the way?
What is the very best we can
do with our depth sensor?
Can we build 3D
models of the world?
And I have a pretty
cool application here.
It's called The Constructor app.
And I'm going to try to make
a model of some of you guys
here in front.
Let's just jump back
to the demo here.
So now you can see
a live view of what
the depth sensor can see.
So you can see right
in front of me,
it can see the 3D
shape of people here.
So now what if we, instead of
taking one depth measurement,
if we start accumulating
all these depth
measurements together?
So if I could ask you
guys to sit really still,
then we can build a
really nice model here.
So I press Record.
And I can keep adding
new information
and keep accumulating more
and more depth measurements.
So now I save it.
So now the model gets optimized.
And the camera is
a little blurry.
I apologize for that.
It looks a lot
better on the screen.
So now we have an
actual 3D model
of the people in this room.
[APPLAUSE]
All right, let's jump
back to our slides.
So to build this 3D model,
again, we need motion tracking.
Motion tracking, as
you probably see,
is one of the core
foundations of Tango.
Almost anything
you do with Tango
will rely on motion tracking.
And then here, obviously, we
need the depth sensor again.
You could use area learning
if you need more accuracy.
But this demo that I just showed
was not using area learning.
So it shows you what you can do
even with just motion tracking
alone.
Let's look at some other
applications that are possible.
Because Tango knows exactly
how your device is moving--
so let's say you're shooting
a video while you're walking.
Tango will know exactly how your
device is moving as you walk.
And obviously you
don't want your device
to shake up and down as
you're making a video.
So because Tango
knows how you move,
it can also compensate for
the motion in your video.
So you can start doing
video stabilization.
And because Tango is
six degrees of freedom,
you can do a full 3D video
stabilization with Tango.
It's not just orientation.
But you can compensate for
all the motions of the camera.
And for this, obviously, again,
you need motion tracking.
And optionally,
you could use that,
if you want to have
more information
about your scene on how
you want to correct it,
or you could it without it.
It depends on how you want
to correct for the motion.
But that is available
if you want.
So now let's look at
a future application.
So imagine if you used area
learning, not just to remember
a few feet in front
of you, but what
if you remember an
entire building, if you
go scan an entire mall,
or an entire museum?
Then Tango could
provide you directions
on how to get from A
to B in that space.
And you could do it in full AR.
The video is a
little choppy here.
You can see on the screen.
You could paint dots on the
floor in augmented reality.
They guide you all
the way from where you
are to where you want to go.
If you want to build something
like this, of course,
motion tracking is one
of your components.
But then to do this, I
guess you need something
like area learning, and not just
area learning on your device.
You need area
learning on steroids.
You want to put area
learning in the cloud,
process very large
amounts of data
if you want to enable
something like this.
So this is one of the
future applications that
can become possible with Tango.
So right now you
understand how Tango works.
You have a bit of an idea
of all the different things
you can do with Tango.
So let's take some time
and just focus on AR,
because what we see is most
of our compelling experiences
tend to be in the AR space.
So let's go step by
step on how you build
augmented reality with Tango.
So let's say we want to do this.
We want to add a virtual
cat into the real world.
Sounds pretty simple, right?
Let's go through step-by-step.
So first let's think
about the real world.
Obviously, the real
world is all in 3D.
And what happens when our
phone looks at the 3D world,
we get to see a 2D
projection of the 3D world
in our camera view.
So if you look at it
from a different angle,
the 3D world gets projected
in 2D in our phone.
So our phone sees something
like this through the camera.
And as you move
around, the 3D world
would get projected in different
ways onto your 2D phone.
So as you move
around, you can see
different angles of the table.
And of course,
this is just video.
This happens automatically.
We don't need to do anything.
But now, if you want
to add a virtual object
into this real world,
it's the same principle.
We have a virtual 3D object.
And we want to show that in
a 2D projection in our world,
in our camera.
So we're going to do the
same thing as what naturally
happens with the camera.
We're going to go from 3D to 2D.
And as we walk around, you
want to get all different 2D
projections of the real world.
Let's try something
simple first.
Let's just try to render
that virtual object alone.
Let's forget about the
real world for a second.
And let me show you a demo here.
So in this demo, I'm
just going to try to add
a virtual object to the world.
We want to be able to see it
from all different angles.
There's our cat.
And then now, as
I walk around, I
can see it from all
different angles.
So it's doing exactly
what we want to happen.
We take our 3D virtual model
and create all different 2D
projections as we walk around.
So now let's try to do a
little bit of a naive step.
Let's take our virtual cat
and just add it together
with a video feed.
Let's just put the two
together in a naive way
and see what happens.
So this time, here's
the real world.
And there's our cat.
So if you put the two
together, it obviously--
it's not quite right.
Even though we're doing
all the rendering good,
we're doing all the
motion good, it still
doesn't look realistic,
because, obviously, we don't
want our cat floating in space.
So to create a
compelling AR experience,
we need to know where we
can put these objects.
We cannot just put
them anywhere we want.
So let's jump to the
slides real quick.
So this is what
we did until now.
We just took our virtual
cat, added it to the world.
Not good.
So what we really
want is we want
to find all the different places
of where we can place our cats.
And luckily, the
Tango SDK allows
you to do this with
just one function call.
You can tap somewhere
on the screen,
and the Tango SDK will tell
you what the local surface is.
It'll tell you where
you can place something.
So it'll give you a
3D point and a normal.
So you could tap
anywhere on the screen,
and Tango will tell
you, here's where
you can place your virtual
objects in the real world.
So if you select
one of those points,
you want to put our
virtual cat right there.
So let's give it a try.
Let's put those two together.
So the next step in our demo,
so again, we see the real world.
And there our cat is now
not floating in space,
but nicely sitting
on the ground.
So this looks a
lot more realistic
than our floating cat.
We can go up close.
And now, since Tango can
understand the world,
I can just tap
somewhere on the screen
and let my cat walk there.
And I can go back on stage
and tap on a higher surface.
And because Tango
fully understands 3D,
[APPLAUSE]
We know exactly where
to jump through.
Again, just I do a
click, and Tango tells me
where the 3D surface is where I
can make my virtual object go.
Let's see if we can go
onto the table here.
There we go.
So this is all pretty cool.
So let me show you where
it's not quite right yet.
So I'm going to put the
cat here behind the table.
And I'm going to move to
the other side of the table.
And you're going to
see what happens.
Again, no good.
So even though our cat
is in the right place,
if I don't hide the cat when
it's behind a physical object,
it doesn't look good again.
So we really want
to know where there
are occlusions in the world.
So let's jump back
to the slides.
So remember we just built
this 3D model with Tango
using a depth sensor?
So what if we use that
to construct a model
of our occlusions in the world?
So instead of showing the
cat through an object,
we can create a simple model
of what the obstacle looks like
and then use it to
hide a part of our cat.
So we can do at least an
approximate occlusion of what
we can see and
what we cannot see.
So let's go to
the demo once more
and show the last version
of the cat AR demo.
So in this application,
we're going
to start out by building
a mesh of the world.
So you can see the gray.
That's the mesh that
we're slowly building.
So as I walk around, I'm
creating a 3D model of what
the environment looks like.
And I can tell Tango
to save the mesh.
So now we have a mesh saved.
So if I go find
my cat somewhere--
so let me ask my cat again
to go behind the table.
So now if I move, my 3D model
can help to hide the cat.
Let me put it back up here.
There we go.
And here we're not
actually hiding the--
it really likes to
jump down there.
OK.
Let me try once more.
There we go.
So I'm actually
still showing the cat
where we would have
rendered it, just
to show you what we're hiding.
And if I come out
from behind the mesh,
we can see that cat again.
You can see it's
not 100% perfect.
The edges are not quite always
exactly at the right place.
But as a developer, you can
kind use some creativity.
Maybe you can blend
the edges a little
and work around some
of those limitations
to make it a really
compelling experience.
Let's jump back to our slides.
So these were all the
steps to go building
in the AR application.
And for all these steps, we have
tools built into the Tango SDK.
So all of these things are
very easy as a developer.
They're just functions
available for you to use.
If you look at what AR can
do, this is an example of--
it's pretty amazing.
It's like one virtual
car, one real car.
If you look on the
roof of the car,
you can even see the reflection
of the building onto the car.
So to create really,
really perfect AR,
there's a lot of
additional steps
on top of just dealing
with occlusions
and geometry of the world.
But even with the
tools we already have,
you can create really
compelling experiences.
It doesn't have to be
picture perfect to make
a really compelling
experience for a user.
Let's talk a little
bit about developers,
how you guys can develop on
top of Tango from within China.
And I want to go through
a number of building
blocks of things that
you need to be developer
and to be successful.
So first, obviously,
you need devices.
You want devices to develop on.
And you want to have
users to have devices
so they can use your apps.
And this is why it's
great that Lenovo
has launched the Tango device,
the Phab 2 Pro, worldwide.
Very soon you
should be expecting
an announcement from Lenovo
about where and when you
can buy it in China.
That's coming up very soon.
This device will be available
in China for purchase.
So first thing you want devices
in China, Lenovo Phab 2 Pro.
Second part, and you probably
know as a user in China,
you don't always get
the latest updates,
because there's multiple
Play Stores available.
And you don't always get
the latest software updates
that are available
through the Play
Store in the rest of the world.
So for Tango we will make
sure that every time we
release a new version
of the Tango software,
we will also release it
in the Lenovo App Store.
So users in China
will always have
the latest and greatest
Tango software, just
like the rest of the world.
So you get Tango
software updates.
The third component,
documentation.
And just today, there was
actually two important launches
that happened.
One is Google made all their
developer documentation
available directly in China.
And at the same time, we
launched a new Tango website
that is compatible with the
content you can view in China.
So I'll show the
link a little later.
But you have all
our documentation,
all our example
apps, all our SDKs.
Everything is there available
from China directly.
And then, of course, when
you build applications,
you want to have a
place to find users.
And Google Play is
a great platform
to find users worldwide.
But then you can use
the Lenovo store.
Lenovo has built a special
Tango section in their app store
to release your apps
to the Chinese market.
So you have both a solution
for the international
and for the Chinese market
to get your apps to users.
So we have these four
components, devices,
software updates, documentation,
and the app store.
So it means, as a
developer in China,
you have all the building
blocks to build compelling Tango
experiences and address
both the Chinese
and the international markets.
So to end, I wanted to give you
the link of our brand new Tango
website.
On this website, you can
find all the documentation.
You can download our SDKs.
We have support for C,
Java, Unity, Unreal.
So everything is there
for you to get started.
And maybe to add one
more thing to this,
because the Asian markets
are really important for us,
we just started staffing up a
new developer engineering team
for the Asia-Pacific markets.
So we want to be here to
support you guys, and make sure
that you have everything
you need to build
really amazing applications.
So go check it out, and
thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
You should all go check out the
Tango booth and the Daydream
booth if you haven't already.
I think we still have an
hour of demos going on.
So if you want to try some
of this with your own hands,
go check out the booth.
Thank you.